We have Olivia and Judah here.
Um,
Olivia wrote The New York Times
bestselling book called Charisma Myth.
If you haven't read it, it's amazing. Um,
and Judah works for Berkeley's
Haas business school and
also worked at Starbucks
and they recently wrote a book called
the Net and the butterfly, um, to,
to help you work on your creative process.
So without any further ado,
let's welcome them to Google
you.
So when we started doing
research for this book,
we came upon this really wild pattern.
And so this is Leo's Dillard.
He went to a lecture in the late
thirties about nuclear physics.
And as he was walking across the street,
literally in mid stride,
he had this realization about how he
could start a nuclear chain reaction using
vision.
Then we get Henri palm cafe.
How'd I do? How'd I do, oh, he Pornchai
Olivia's native French speakers.
Every time I come up a French
word, it's a nightmare. Kills me.
So he was working on an incredibly
difficult series of math functions.
And one morning as he was getting
on a bus to go to a conference,
he remembers this very distinctly.
He put his foot on the step,
the first step of the bus,
and suddenly it came to him.
He knew what his answer was,
so then we come to Nicola Tesla who
is trying to work on a functioning,
alternating current generator. He's
walking through a park with his friends.
When suddenly he realizes
exactly how he's going to do it.
He needs one of the engines to rotate
in the opposite direction from the other
two that had gone to be
part of the generator.
This also brings us to
Heisenberg Heisenberg, sorry.
For those of you who are fans,
if you type hot,
if you now type Heisenberg into the
Google search engine, that's what you get.
He has now eclipsed Verner.
Walter has a coat's Verner Verner.
Heisenberg has a conversation with Niels
Bohr and Copenhagen late night walking
home through a park.
What happens? He's like,
can the universe really be
a strange as I think it is?
He comes up with the uncertainty
principle. This just keeps happening.
Girdle and Einstein famous for taking
walks together in Princeton at the
Institute for Advanced Study,
Darwin had something called the sand walk.
What he would do is he would start at
the corner there and he put a couple of
stones,
he'd stack them and he'd walk the sand
walk while he thought about the problem
and he'd knock a stone off every
lap. And he knew, he's like,
this is a three stone problem.
There's a six stone problem.
But he would walk his way to the answer.
Same thing with Tchaikovsky,
three hour walks every afternoon
and then we get Emmanuel con to it.
It said you could set your watch by his
walks cause he'd walk around the town
square the same time every day.
You keep going back in history.
It keeps showing up.
Aristotle who founded a school and they
were known as the peripatetics. Why?
Cause they walked around
as they philosophized and
then of course we had the
famous story of Archimedes
who's stepping into the tub,
watches the water displacement
and suddenly realizes,
this is how I'm going to figure out
if the crown is solid gold or not by
checking its density.
Something very strange is going on,
but the story keeps happening over
and over and it's not just walking.
It happens with sleep.
So this is Dimitri men delay.
If you spent three years working on a
chemistry textbook driven crazy that he
couldn't put it into more order
and during a feverish nap,
woke up with a picture of this in his
head, wrote it down as fast as he could.
Okay,
who's our neck? Oh, you're
going to hate me again. August.
Yeah.
Are you going to make
me do it? You Go. Kukula
had I do know nightmare.
We're moving on.
So chemist and chemists,
18 hundreds everybody's trying to figure
out the shape of benzene at the time.
Nobody can do it.
He has a dream of a snake eating its own
tail and suddenly realizes that benzine
is a rang. This literally creates
structural organic chemistry,
which creates the tar
and die or industries.
It creates the pharmaceutical industries.
If you ever wondered why so many
pharmaceutical companies are German,
because he was German.
It started as first lab in Bond Ramanujan.
Famous numbers theorists from India used
to say that the goddess would write the
equations on his tongue and his dreams,
and so he'd wake up with stuff like this.
Finally Salvador Dali. Now he knew
exactly what he was doing was sleep.
He would sit down in a straight back
chair and he would hang his arm over the
side holding a metal key with a metal
plate underneath and as he dozed off,
he would drop the key and the key would
hit the plate, make a rattle, wake him up.
And as soon as he woke up,
he just start drawing and we all know
what those drawings ended up looking like.
So here we have all of these
geniuses who are accessing,
walking and sleeping in different
ways to come up with these amazing
breakthroughs. What is it that they
figured out? What did they know?
And as another example,
I want to tell you that when I was
showering this morning thinking about this
talk coming here, I suddenly realized
I wanted to show you all this.
Okay?
[inaudible]
I'm going to come back to that.
I'm going to tell you why I wanted
to show you that in a minute.
It's not just cause it's
really funny with which it is.
We have the capacity to know so much.
When we look up at the stars were
amazed at how many stars are,
I were amazed at the sheer immensity
of the universe and our place in it.
But the reality is that
when we look up at the sky,
that's how much we're actually seeing.
Okay?
We are not truly aware
of how much is out there.
We're not truly aware of
how much more we could see.
And the same is true of how
we access our own brains.
We are not aware of just how
much we have the capacity to do.
And what we wrote about in this book is
not only what is this physical mechanism
inside everyone's brains, and I want to
be clear, it's, it's not just geniuses.
The geniuses have the same exact physical
structures in their brain that every
one of you has.
But it's a question of accessing it.
It's a question of trusting it.
And so what we're gonna do is we're going
to talk a lot about tools because the
thing about breakthroughs,
creativity,
innovation is there a lot of theories
and people lay out theories all the time.
But this is,
this is a craft.
This is like an artisan's
craft and just like artisans,
there are tools and you have to practice
with those tools in order to gain
mastery. And that's really what we
were interested in in this book.
So to explain what the
process is in your brain,
we made a short animation that we want
to show you and the story we're going to
tell you is true and everything going
on inside the brain is also true.
Florida 1965 the rolling stones
are on their first US tour,
but they're not the rolling stones yet.
They're about as popular
as Herman's hermits.
What they're in need of is a breakthrough.
Hit a number one song and no one
knows it more than Keith Richards.
One night in his motel room,
Richards was trying to write that song.
So what's going on inside his brain?
He's attempting to have this breakthrough.
This is the executive of Keith Richards,
his brain,
it's focused on task and has a goal.
Write a hit song.
There's just one problem. It's not
very good at breaking news by itself.
See the executive network is great when
you need to make a list or complete a
project, but when it comes to having
a breakthrough, it needs some help.
That night Richard's fell asleep and no
longer on task is executive went to talk
to another network that
lies deeper in the brain.
Now what we're about to show you
is not unique to Keith Richards.
You have the same exact room
in your brain. We all do.
We just don't access it enough.
This is your genius lounge,
about 10 different brain regions in here
all hanging out talking. There's Mozart,
Leonardo Davinci, Mary Curie, Einstein,
welcome to the part of your
brain that's working on stuff.
When you don't think you're
working on stuff that night,
Richard's is executive walked in
and said, quiet. All right everyone.
We need a breakthrough. Hit. Now go.
The executive went in busy itself,
but something mindless in this case sleep,
but it can be doing the dishes or the
laundry or taking a shower. Meanwhile,
the geniuses started sharing all kinds
of information from art to music to
childhood memories.
This was the sum total of Keith Richards.
His experience and knowledge and
the combining created his intuition.
It created a breakthrough.
Richard's woke up in the middle
of the night and began to play.
That was how the rolling stones got
their breakthrough hit satisfaction,
but it is not just Keith Richards.
We all have an executive and a
genius loungey and our brains.
The key to having more breakthroughs is
learning how to switch between the two
modes.
All right?
That was me doing the voice work and I'm
going to pick that up as a second job
if I can.
Um,
that literally is what happens in your
brain when you have a breakthrough that
is literally where you go
when you're more creative.
I'm sure all of you have had
moments when you were on a run,
when you were just
spacing out during a walk,
when you were in the shower and send
them that. You just realized something.
And the reason it works is
because you're executive mode.
The part in the front of your brain that
takes care of everything that gets you
places on time. That finishes projects.
It has to go quiet, but it can't just,
it doesn't just go quiet. If you tell it
to you, it gets annoyed if you do that.
So you have to fake it out.
You have to give it a goal.
We're going to walk to the store now,
the executives happy.
We're going to finish the dishes,
we're going to take a shower.
The executives like, great, I have
something I'm going to finish.
Thank goodness I'm so happy.
This is the case and it sorted,
but it's kind of mindless, but you don't
have to concentrate hard on it. Judah.
Yes. If you're wondering what we mean by
if you tell the executive to go quiet,
it gets annoyed. How many of you
have tried meditation, right?
How many of you have experienced
the monkey mind? Exactly.
So you know what we're talking about.
That's what happens when you try to
have the consecutive to go quiet.
You're welcome.
And so,
but if you give it this kind of
mindless task, what happens is power.
Literally power reroutes from the
executive and goes to this genius lounge,
this default mode network and it's like
the espresso machine gets fired up and
all the different parts of the network
started drinking coffee and they start
getting jazz and the different
parts of this network,
they encompass so many various parts.
You have your own personal memories,
you have your every prediction
and your future prediction.
You have your sense of empathy trying to
figure out how somebody else's feeling.
You have your own sense of self, your met
a narrative that's moving through this.
You have your inferior pride or Lowe's,
which is all the physical sensation
coming into you. It goes on and on.
The sheer number of things
that this network is engaged
in and what it does when
you're on some sort of random little
task is it starts mixing and matching
information.
It starts playing around is if you had a
pile of Lego's and it's just making all
these legos together and then
holding them up and saying,
is this a brilliant idea? Is that
this is a brilliant idea. Now,
one of the keys to this is that it's
not that the executive plays no role.
As you saw on the video, the geniuses keep
looking to the executive. They're like,
hey,
we came up with this.
What do you think the executive
is actually saying yes or no?
And so at some point you're geniuses
come up with something really good,
your executive says yes and that's when
it enters your level of awareness that
your Aha moment.
Now the science kind of stops at the
moment at how does your brain determine
what's a good idea and what's not a good
idea? How does it know to wake you up?
We don't know yet,
but we do know that this is
what's happening and there
are certain things that
we all can do to capitalize
on this natural ability.
And the first one is plasticity.
So the reason I showed you this
video was for a very specific reason.
I'll show it to you again.
Watch the defense.
[inaudible] stands there.
They just look at the quarterback.
And the reason it works is because what's
happening is not within their realm of
what's possible. They don't
notice it, they don't expect it,
and so they can't think of what to do.
He literally has the ball and is walking
by seven people who could tackle him at
any moment and nobody moves
because they can't put it together.
That is what plasticity allows us to do.
Brain plasticity is our ability
to build new neural connections,
to understand new thoughts.
To give you an idea of what plasticity is,
I want to show you this,
so this is a video by drew Barry who
does amazing biological animations.
Highly recommend you go check
out his stuff, it's brilliant,
and here he's got a single neuron and
what you're watching happen is the Axon or
the,
I mean that the Soma or the body,
the big bulb there is what's sort
of giving out pulses of electricity.
There's new research out actually that
it's not just the body that does that,
but we don't need to get into that
right now and we're moving along to the
dendrites.
These are the parts of the brain that
just branch out like a river and the parts
of the neurons and just go out.
Now,
now and along them you
have these little heads,
these little buds and on
the top of these buds,
that's where you have
neurotransmitter receptors.
The places that accepted things like
Serotonin, dopamine, neuro epinephrin.
The thing you need to realize is
this is not a static situation.
What you're seeing right here is you're
watching a new neurotransmitter receptor
be born for the first time and now all
of a sudden there is a new way for the
neurons to connect to one another and
because there's a new way for them to
connect to one another,
there's a new thought that can happen
because that's one of the most important
things for you to understand.
Your thoughts are not chemical,
your thoughts are not electrical,
your thoughts or structural.
Your brain is literally building
new neurotransmitter receptors every
millisecond and in doing that you have
the ability to build new connections and
having the ability to build
new connections gives you
the ability to have a new
thought.
Basically Messenger RNA sends a message
to transfer RNA. This is transfer RNA.
Look at the very top, you see
the ACC, those are amino acids,
this little factory stacks, amino
acids, one on top of the other.
And then when it's done it cuts them off.
And then this amazing
magical thing happens.
The protein folds show.
You've heard of this in this case
and what we're talking about,
these proteins fold and form
new neurotransmitter receptors.
So it's our ability to do that.
That makes us plastic.
Your brain is structural.
You're building the actual
infrastructure to have a new thought.
And so one of the first things that you
all have to get better at that everyone
has to get better at is getting
more practiced at doing this.
So people who tell themselves, I'm not
creative, I don't think of these things,
I'm not that sort of person that is
equivalent to sitting on the couch for two
years. And then somebody tells you to do
10 pushups and you can't. And you say,
I guess I'm just weak now. I'm just
forever out of shape. It's hopeless now,
you know, that's not the case. You know,
you just need to work out and get fit.
The same is true about your own ability
to have a breakthrough about your own
ability to be creative.
We have become neuro couch potatoes.
We do the same things over and over.
And when we do the same
things over and over,
we don't challenge our brains to
build new neurotransmitter receptors,
which means we can't build a new thought.
And that's why we get stuck.
That's why many of us end up
like the defense on that team.
Something new has happened
and we can't process it.
We don't know what it
is and it walks by us.
This is what it's like when
you lack neuroplasticity,
but you're trying to come up with a new
thought and there are tools that can
help you actually get to
something that's more like this.
And so that's what this is
really about is the tools.
It's about changing your neurons from
this to this. You want all those branches,
you want all that connectivity.
That's what you're looking for.
What do you think this is?
Okay.
Don't be shy. You have no way of
knowing. So there's shout stuff out.
Paint
fabric.
Okay.
See that, feel that push, feel that push.
That's like trying to do a pushup
when you're out of shape, smoke
colored liquid
turbulence. What was it? Mold.
So this is ink drops in water
and you were getting there.
You are all in and around it,
but now that I've told you
it's inked drops in water,
you're looking at it again and your
brain is actually forming a new set of
neural connections to
make that into a memory,
to understand that that's what that is.
You've broken open into a new space,
exposing ourselves to things we don't
know to things we don't understand the
things we don't see a lot.
That is literally one of the greatest
ways to create neuroplasticity.
This is one of our favorites.
Eric wine and Meyer,
eh? Okay, you let it go.
He has climbed the seven tiles
mountains on all seven continents.
There's just one funny thing is if
that weren't enough, he's blind.
So how does he do this?
How does he possibly climb this mountain?
Something called the brain port.
See this little thing.
He puts that on his tongue.
It is connected to these glasses
where you see a camera on the front.
The camera takes in the light signals
and it becomes electrical impulses that
are signaled to his tongue.
The tongue signals those into his brain
because the person who invented this
Paul backer, Eda said, we
don't see with our eyes.
We see with our brains are,
I just happened to take in the light,
but if we can figure out another
way to take in the light signals,
our brains will figure out a way to
see because our brains are so plastic
because we can create so many
new connections and little
by little he learned to
read the signals from his tongue and he
could actually start to see even though
there was nothing coming through his eyes.
Another story we love as a young
woman in China, 24 years old,
walks into the hospital kind of
dizzy. They do a, they do a cat scan.
She has no cerebellum.
She was born without one.
It was full of liquid in her head.
She shouldn't have been able to ever
walk much less hold down a job function,
but the other parts of her brain started
to take on these other abilities are
our ability to be plastic is almost
never ending. It's astounding.
We just need to actually work the muscle
and it's incredibly important that we
work the muscle number of things
that we like to suggest, uh,
come to work one day dressed completely
differently than you ever do.
If your address down sort of person
like I am where a suit and a tie fancy
shoes,
first of all,
the fabric will move against
you differently and it will
give different physical
impulses to your brain, which goes
right into your default network.
The other thing that will happen is
people will respond to you differently.
You're going to get a whole different
set of information from people as they
react in these different
ways and you're going to,
you're just going to take this all in.
If you're,
if you're a woman and you tend
to wear heels and dresses,
wear pants and a pair of sneakers or
vice versa on both the men and the women.
Just change it up.
Another one that I like to do is borrow
somebody else's playlist that you don't
know what it is and just listened to it
for the day. Just the songs that come up,
the way they make you feel,
what you're experiencing with it.
We'd like to talk about eating things you
are narrowly never eat will then cause
the brain signals are new. You have to
sort of process what is this new thing.
This one is really difficult, especially
given the political situation right now,
but read political magazines
you ordinarily wouldn't read.
Listen to talk radio you ordinarily
wouldn't talk to it might not be worth it
from the stress level and we
understand that, but it's another way.
Just taking a totally
different information or
watch movies you would never
watch.
Read a book you would never read.
Get into a conversation with someone you'd
never get into a conversation too and
just take in things that are brand new.
When you go to home tonight,
take a completely different route if
you can and just notice what's new.
Notice what's different.
Change up your routine.
Routine is the death of plasticity.
You're wanting to just change
it up and see what's going on.
See what you can bring in that's new,
right?
I suggest all of you go and visit
Olivia if you can and hang out with her
chickens and her bs because you probably
don't do that very often and watching
chickens is actually kind of fascinating.
They call it chicken TV
and you can just wash them,
but they behave in a way you just
don't notice. You just don't see.
This is one of the reasons you feel more
alive when you go on vacation because
everything's new and it's popping
in your brain. When you're,
when the plasticity is going,
you feel it.
It fundamentally feels
good and feels different.
Another piece about this is new
information you want to take in.
Things you ordinarily
would never hear about,
would never see,
would never do so.
Try a sport you've never tried.
If you're more physically oriented,
ride a dirt bike, go mountain
biking in Moab, gone a trap. Ps,
be careful. I won't hurt myself
terribly on a chat piece,
but take in all of these different pieces
because the physical reality that you
engage in is going straight into your
default network and it's causing all kinds
of new things to pop.
But one of the reasons new information
is so incredibly important is because
there's this other element to the
way that our default network works,
and we couldn't get into it
in the animation because it
was a little too complex.
But here's what happens right now.
You're paying attention to me,
or at least I hope you're
paying attention to me,
and you're creating memories in your
brain and what your hippocampus does,
which is what's in charge
of creating your memories,
is it takes all this information and it
kind of puts it on a shelf and it waits
to encode it as longer term memories.
And then when you're off task,
when you're not really focused, your
hippocampus starts to form these memories.
Meanwhile, you're off task. So your
default network is also activated.
All of a sudden your hippocampus
does a very strange thing.
It takes random shards and combinations
of these new memories and it throws them
like little sparks into
your default network.
So your default network
has all this information,
kind of like building a fire and then
your hippocampus throws a new information
in as a spark to light it.
So if you don't have new information,
your default network, your Genius Lounge
just keeps spinning on the same stuff.
It can't really bus due to something new.
This is one of the reasons very often
people who have breakthroughs do their
work and then also have
some kind of hobby,
they have something else they're really
interested in because that brings in the
new information that starts getting
things to bang into each other in new and
novel ways, in ways they weren't
expecting. So if all you do is work,
it's going to be that much harder to have
that creative breakthrough because you
want to bring that new information and
from somewhere else, from something else,
something that's just different.
So how do you access it?
How do you actually get into this mode?
She didn't take it. And
Stephanie, for instance, um,
one of the ways that we like to explain
the importance of plasticity is, um,
if you look at a,
at a martial artists,
so say someone who's doing an actual
useful martial arts like Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu and knots and sissy
practice like karate. Um,
you know that once I'm slightly biased,
you know that there's one thing
that is the actual techniques.
What are the moves, how can you roll?
And then something completely different,
which is the physical conditioning
plasticity is like doing cardio. Um,
the plasticity on its own won't,
isn't necessarily the exact,
the exercise for plasticity isn't
necessarily the one that will lead you to
breakthrough.
Just like having a lot more physical
power won't necessarily get you to win on
the Mat.
I was regularly tied into
knots by my Sensei who was
a shrimp was about this big,
right? He could take on and
85 kilo guy without a problem.
But it's part of what will make
you better at the final result.
So the same way you do cardio
it regardless of which,
regardless of of which end
sport you're going to do,
you want to get better plasticity cause
it's a good conditioning to then use the
breakthrough tools. Am I making
any sense? Yeah, please, please,
please jump in, ask questions if
you have objections raised them. Um,
we really encouraged the
debate in the moment.
There might or might not be a Qa period
at the end. So take advantage of it.
All yours
objections.
So the question was what are good
contrasts in terms of your work versus a
hobby?
What are good ways to create
that differentiation so
that you get the most out
of the new information
to get the novel ideas?
And so there are two things
going on in your question.
Some of the things you suggested go to
what we have up here, which is accessing,
so sleep, walking. These are less hobbies.
I like to think of sleep as a hobby.
That's a great idea.
But these are less hobbies and they're
more ways to access your network their
way. There are doorways into that sort
of mindless state where you're sort of
floating and you're not paying
too much attention to anything.
Then there's an actual
hobby where you are focused.
So actual hobbies can be anything.
Woodworking is great.
Watching movies is great. Or reading
books, cooking, rock climbing,
cycling, it doesn't really
matter. Collecting stamps. Yes,
I have an objection. Um, personally
I've always found, uh, things
that'll wordless are better for
the mind wandering. So for example,
when you watch a movie, even if it's
a movie that you know really well,
the verbal center processing center
of your brain is still active.
Whereas if you're rock climbing, if
you're bullish, you're beekeeping,
you're usually braiding yourself for
the many mistakes you've just done.
But if you're climbing,
if you're running without music,
okay,
in my experience that just works better
because of the lack of a distraction
from the verbal processor.
And, and just to be clear, there's
no absolute answers to these things.
You find your own way. Um,
cause I would turn around so I,
my mind will wander very
often when I'm reading.
You ever read the same paragraph over
and over and then you're like, oh,
I keep reading the same paragraph.
It's cause you've mind wandered.
So for some people, absolutely the verbal
processor completely gets in the way.
For other people it just
sorta it can shut down.
So you're just looking for what works for
you and what interests you because you
don't want it to be a force. You want it
to be something that you actually liked.
But the, the key is to give it time,
give yourself time to truly do it,
give yourself time to truly learn about
it because that's going to create new
and different information that can then
combine with the work you're doing to
show you novel new possibilities. Does
that make sense? It does. Thank you.
You got it. And so to
continue, Oh yes, please.
What does meditation fit into all
of those? The meditation question.
Excellent question.
Um,
I'll start and then new
debated in the book.
Just how deep to get into this because
it seems like there are some dark sides
to many practices have a medic
meditation. And so, so meditation,
ironically, you would think meditation
would put you into that kind of state.
However, the majority of meditation
practice is actually quiet.
Your default network,
they actually make it happen.
The less one of the reasons is because
there's a part of your default network
that is all about your Meta awareness.
So it's all about what
do I think about myself?
You ever get caught in a loop thinking
bad thoughts about yourself that your
default network,
this is one of the regions.
Depression and creativity get connected
very often cause it's the same network
in your brain responsible for both.
So in meditation quiets that network,
it can help you with depression.
So at the same time,
caveat warning,
at the same time,
the default network gets strengthened
when you're in a meditative state.
Literally your gray matter chickens,
oh, that's not where I'm going.
Where were you going
please? Judah and I have
slightly different, um,
approaches to, well actually a
lot of things, but meditation,
I'm the ruthlessly pragmatic
one in, um, in this duo.
So the way I look at meditation
is really like a toolbox. Um,
or like a cheese board or something.
I'm the same way.
You use a hammer or a
wrench for the same purpose,
the same way that personally I would
recommend using metta or Vipassana for the
same purpose. It's, it really is the
same way where you talk about yoga,
it runs the gamut from the 180 degree
Celsius Bikram rooms to the uh,
you know, hold the mountain pose
for three days kind of things.
Meditation for me is the same way.
It's a toolbox.
So it really depends as to
what you're going after.
And you could be going for
emotional healing. You could,
you could be going for internal insight.
Um,
the way I tend to see it,
and there's a lot of push backs is
just one personal way of seeing it. Um,
from easiest to hardest is how much
sedatives you give your monkey mind.
So TM,
transcendental meditation is a really
nice entry point into meditation because
it gives you what is direct drugs
for the monkey mind, which is words.
So you get a mantra to repeat.
And in some traditions it's
considered sacred and personal.
In some other scientific studies,
it seems that pretty much any sound that
you repeat can have the same effect.
Um,
but you get some thing mental to focus
on in various traditions of the passing
of insight, you can focus on any
object of meditation, be it the,
um, a candle. Your breath is
usually the most portable. Um,
for a lot of people,
like probably us in this room,
that's the nice dry,
comfortable work of the mind.
And for a lot of us it's easier.
Probably most of us in Silicon Valley,
it's easier to work on something like
insight meditation because it's all in the
mind. It's a lot easier than the messy,
ugly, uncomfortable work of the heart,
which is the realm of, um, practices
like metta, loving kindness.
Don't lend compassion.
Please don't get into,
don't learn until you're
damn sure you're ready.
You're taking on the sufferings
of the rest of the world. Um,
so if you want to grow your heart,
you're going to use one too.
If you want to grow your plasticity,
you're going to want to go.
Or another the caveat I
was going into his, um,
there are some forms of meditation.
Um,
I personally would not recommend to
beginners. Zen is a good example.
People have been known to go into
schizophrenia episodes on zen retreats.
Have me, if you have ever gone on a silent
retreat, please raise your hands. Okay.
For those of you who haven't,
please, please, please, please,
please consider going on one.
There are very few experience of which
I would say without the slightest.
Second of hesitation,
it's a life changing experience.
I would say that about going on a silent
retreat. Those of you who have gone,
has this been your experience?
Please feel free to say no if not okay.
Now that's an answer. It's really
good. I hate silent retreats,
but it's kind of like meditation
is training for your mind.
It's like going to the gym for your mind
and usually by two thirds of the way
into a meditation retreat,
you are certain that you are failing the
meditation practices failing this whole
idea stupid and you
want to go home anyway.
And there's a certain arc that you
will see your own mind go through.
The caveat that I was going into is that
meditation can in certain circumstances
help you through depression. It can
also precipitate depression. Um,
so as with any other tool,
it's useful to have good mentors,
teachers,
or they can be in the form of
books. Humans, it doesn't matter,
but who can guide you along the way so
you get sure that you don't get stuck
into a vicious cycle that through
meditation can actually worsen depression.
Am I making sense? Does anyone have any
questions? Comments? Objections, please?
Okay.
Yeah. Meditation can in some
cases worse than depression,
especially if you're on retreat. Yes.
But it can also get two out of it.
It can also get you out of it.
There's a fantastic, if you,
if it gets you into it and
then gets you out of it,
that bones is the nicely.
So here you're saying it's an it as
if it were a single thing. It's not,
you've got first a bazillion different
traditions of meditation and each
experience we haven't, it's
going to be different. Um,
there is a book that I recommend
very, very, very highly.
It's called the mindful
way through depression.
It is one of the best books
I've seen on those two things.
But there's um,
if you're just starting to meditation,
get out of your mind and into your life,
but the classic favoritist would
be wherever you go. There you are.
And those are all really
good introductions as to
seeing where your mind can
take you and learning
to drop below the mind.
Learning to just because something is
in your head doesn't mean it has any
validity whatsoever.
Yeah.
Okay. All yours. Okay.
One last thing I got there I
was just saying is that it,
it has been shown to
increase the gray matter,
matter in your default network
and increase the connections.
And so what can happen is,
even though you may not go into a mind
wandering state of creativity while in
the meditative state,
when you come out,
you're kind of charged and
ready to be stronger with it.
Talk about the guy or vacation,
it makes you smarter. Sorry,
talk about the guy ratification and
it makes you stronger and smarter.
It increases the folds in certain
parts of your gray matter. And, um,
I pronounce the gamification.
You might not as what threw me off,
it doesn't matter. Go, we
have slight differences in
pronunciation as he gets it.
Um,
and the,
then the complexity of the folding in
that part of your brain is directly
related to your, uh, rapidity
in processing information.
So it literally can make you smarter.
You're gonna explain it a lot better.
Sound good.
Um,
and so the more you're, the more your
neurons are closer to each other,
the more they're wrapped
around each other.
More surface area they can
get into contact with kind
of the way your genes are
wrapped up in a ball, the more chances
there are for the new connections.
So that's why it can improve what's going
on. Again, your brain is structural,
so as you, as you strengthen
the structure of your brain,
you strengthen your ability to have
these breakthroughs. And so medic, well,
meditation is or narrowly not an access
point. It's a strengthening point.
So it's a plasticity strengthening point.
The access points are
things like taking naps.
Salvador Dali discovered the power of
the hypnagogic state when you're just
falling asleep and you're in that liminal
in between space and other people have
discovered the hypnopompic, which is
when you're just coming out of it,
you know when somebody says sleep on it,
that's a real thing because
when you go to sleep,
your default network starts working on
things and right as you're waking up it
tends to tell you things.
And so in the book we talked about Adam
shy or who's one of the cofounders,
a Siri, and this is just a general
practice of his, he goes to sleep,
focuses on an idea specific problem he
has and that's using his executive to
site.
This is what we're working on.
And then he just allows us default
network to do its thing in at night.
And then when he wakes up, he kind of
checks in. He's like, what did it tell me?
And it usually told him something.
He writes it down, he then gets up,
goes to his desk, goes back
to his executive network
and starts working it out.
And you see this happen all the time.
Einstein famously went to his friend one
day after 10 years in 1905 working on
his theories about light and some
alternating and time. And he's like,
you know what, I give up. I'm done.
And he went home and he went to
sleep and he wakes up and Voila,
he comes back to see his friend. He's
like, I have it. Thank you so much.
But here's the thing about breakthroughs.
That was in it.
He then spent six weeks with his
executive function, writing it all out,
getting it all straight,
so there's this constant back and forth.
This is interplay between the two.
That is so important and so
when you access this mode,
you have to also remember to use your
executive to focus you on the issue at
hand to say, okay, this is
what I want to think about.
This is what I'm going to do now.
I'm going to go take a walk.
Now I'm going to go take a nap.
Now I'm going to go for a swim.
Now I'm just going to sit in this hammock
and let myself just sort of wander off.
I'm going to pick up this book,
but I'm not going to be,
I'm not going to be focused
on like finishing the chapter.
I'm just going to let myself read the
book and see if I kind of wander off,
see if something just comes out of it.
Or if you're very good at meditating,
sit down for a 10 2030 minutes, sit.
And then when you come out of it say,
I now want to think about this.
Go for a walk.
Cause you've just sort of done an awesome
workout for your default network and
it's sort of primed and ready to go.
And then you have to let go and
let it sort of do its thing.
One of the issues with accessing it
is because of the world we live in.
We live in a world where we
are on task all the time.
And one of the interesting things is
Douglas Rushkoff and author has this
fascinating concept where he said,
we have all this technology,
all these machines and yet
we're busier than ever.
Weren't they supposed to make our lives
easier? Why is this? And his theory is,
is that we have internalized machine time.
We actually operate at the pace and rate
of the machines that are supposed to be
helping us. And so we answer
emails at all times of the night.
We answer phone calls
whenever we're on constantly.
And the problem with being on constantly
is you never access your default mode.
You never accessed the genius lounge,
and therefore you never give yourself
the chance to have the brilliant ideas to
have the great breakthrough.
The interesting thing is that
to have a true breakthrough,
we need to pull back and step into
human time. We need to slow down,
we need to allow that pace to happen.
We operate better.
When we do that, we just forget, get
overwhelmed and then go, go, go, go, go.
And it's not helpful.
So part of the challenge with accessing
this is allowing yourself to slow down,
is allowing yourself to re enter human
time to do things like walk and nap and
rest.
Aw,
the experience of art is a wonderful
way to access your network.
You just look up at a picture like this
and the sheer immensity of it all and
how small we are. And we are aware
of something larger than ourselves.
And the research shows,
we just,
we open up into a whole different space
and we open up our brains into a whole
different space and different
connections occur, different,
different parts of our brains start
talking and we just were open to this and
this also makes us slow down.
You ever see anybody just like running
along the rim of the Grand Canyon when
you come upon something that produces all,
you slow down.
When you walk up to a redwood,
you slowed down and you just
kind of sit there and say,
my God,
you don't even have to believe in God.
And that kind of comes out of your math
because we're just aware of this larger
entity in the universe.
And so go and look out.
Even just looking at across the bay,
we'll do this or look out at the ocean
or go up to the top of Mount Tam and just
that just luck.
The grand vistas will ignite this in us.
We'll bring it out of us.
I want to talk a little bit
about constraints and the
concept of Wabi Sabi cause
constraints can be incredibly helpful
when it comes to accessing the sort of
breakthrough ability.
Wabi Sabi is this Japanese design
concepts where you start with the flaw,
the flaws, you're your zero
point and you integrate it.
The flaws not to be gotten rid
of the flaws, not a problem.
The flaw actually directs the way
in which you're going to design.
And I love what street artists
do with this stuff, right?
So a crack in the wall becomes Spider
Mans Web and a railing becomes fun for
Calvin and Hobbes and this
guy is breaking out of jail.
And this one,
they've turned the,
the breaking down of the plaster on the
outside wall into a factory and it's a
coming out of the smokestack.
This kid's having a good time.
And here we've got camels making their
way in a caravan and all of this is from,
they saw a floss,
something was wrong.
And then they use that to define how
they were going to create the art.
And so the question becomes,
what's the flaw in your system?
What's your biggest obstacle?
If you start from that point and not say,
how do I get rid of it?
But say how is this my start point?
It creates all kinds of creative
abilities, creative capacities.
The flaw acts as sort of the access
point into your default network.
And so one way you can do this,
and you can do this with teams as
well as you build a constraint box.
And we have found this
to be really useful.
We did this with Genentech a little bit
ago and it was very helpful because they
were talking about how annoying
the federal regulations were.
So we spun it around and we were like,
well let's talk about
what are the constraints?
And what you do is you start to
lay out the constraints, right?
Dave is a serious problem for me.
So as the FDA,
so is the cash flow and it's really
not sexy. What we're talking about,
it's gonna be hard to get
anybody interested in it.
So these are some of your constraints
and you just get a sense of them.
You lay them out so they
don't get overwhelming.
The next thing you do is you start talking
about your assumptions because very
often you're assuming things that
aren't right that aren't true,
and if you don't write
them down and look at them,
they're just going to stymie you the
whole way. So no one's going to listen.
Angela hates this idea 18 months to
see results. It's cost prohibitive.
You just lay it all out there.
You look at it and you
question all these assumptions.
Are they really constraints or are they
just things that you've assumed their
conversations you haven't had?
And the reason you do it in this form
is because what happens in the end is it
this becomes your solution space.
You've now defined where you can be free.
You've defined the space where your
default network can now try any number of
things. So as opposed to these things
hemming you in and locking you in,
they turn around and free you
because now you know that you don't
have to bother looking at those things.
You don't have to bother
beating your head against them.
And now you've got this
space that's opened up.
And that freedom is what
allows the default network
to start to truly function.
And so especially when
you do this with a team,
it's amazing what comes out
and why you start finding out.
But there are all these assumptions on
the table that have stopped people from
getting interested in things that
weren't even correct in the first place.
And little by little people
started realize, oh, but
you know what we can do? Oh,
you know, we can do. And
once you're in that space,
now your default network
is alive and functioning.
And so this is one of the
way the constraints can act
as a really powerful tool
to get you into this Roman Mars of
99% invisible, a really fun podcast.
He has a great ted talk talking
about flags and he's like,
you should be able to draw your
flag on a three by five note card.
And everybody thinks it's
ridiculous and crazy. But he's like,
that's one of the best constraints you
can have because it's going to drive you
to making a really excellent flag and
you can use that kind of constraint on
anything. Can you express it
in a three by five note card?
Well then you probably don't
understand it well enough. Yes.
What do you call it? The default network.
Ah, why do I call it the default network?
I don't, I'm quoting. Um, when
you're on task and doing something,
it goes more quiet.
When you're off task,
your brain defaults to this network.
It just,
this is where it goes every time.
So that's why it's called
the default mode network.
And one of the funny pieces is that
the person who discovered it dark,
just dark and Marcus recall to
do, okay, we'll leave it alone.
The way he figured it out was he was
noticing that when he had people in Fmr
eyes and told them to just
hang on a second, just wait,
don't think about anything.
We have to do something over here.
All of a sudden all this activities
showed up in their brains and everyone was
like, oh, it's just static.
It's just noise, whatever.
And then one day he
walks out of a meeting,
he's wandering down a hall
and it just showed up.
The idea showed up. And so what
happened was he was thinking about this,
he was thinking about this,
and then when he was off task,
wandering down a hall is default network.
The brain defaulted to it and then it
gave him an answer to a question he'd been
asking, which is, what's up with
all this noise? And the FMA? Yes,
it's, it's, it's, it's because it's this,
it's this place where all these different
pieces are coming together and talking
to each other and right. And they're
just sort of putting things together.
So we've discovered it.
It truly is the engine of our creativity.
That's what we've been
starting to find out.
And so these are all just ways you
can actually get into it and use it.
Focus yourself on it.
One of the things,
and we talked about this a lot
in the beginning of the book,
can we give a kitchen recipe for this?
Can we say one cup of butter? You know,
two eggs, some sugar, some chocolate
chips, Vala you'll have a breakthrough.
And the answer is no, it's,
it's a nonlinear process.
It's an emergent process and so you
have to give yourself time with it.
But what we're teaching you is that you
can actually set conditions to make it
far more likely that it will happen.
Switching, I want to make a slight,
a slight switch now to
associative thinking,
which in the end is truly what
your default network is doing.
And so I'm going to show you something
that will both raise your plasticity but
also kind of get into
associative thinking.
I'm somebody left their GoPro on the
ground and a squirrel picked it up.
Okay?
Okay. So I dunno about you, but
I've never seen anything like that.
That is literally a squirrels
I view of the world.
And so it does a couple of things.
One,
it forces this growth of plasticity
because you're like, oh my God.
It's like it's this big and it's moving
on branches you could never move on and
it's moving so quickly through the tree.
I used to move through trees very slowly
and all of this is new and new and new
and then at the same time it,
it adds to this piece that we
call it associative thinking,
so all the media about artificial
intelligence and how it's going to replace
human beings and Yada Yada,
Yada.
Most people who are aware and know that
there's this big leap between where AI
is at the moment,
which is amazingly good at pattern
recognition and the data crunching and the
intuitive inferential leaps between ideas
and that's something that human beings
are still particularly good at and it's
the association of the different ideas,
what sometimes known as
abductive reasoning to have
a little bit of data here
and then to get a whole theory out of it
here and this is what the default mode
network gives us.
It is what takes different pieces of
data and puts them together and to whole
new conceptions,
whole new theories.
And so having experiences
that are completely different.
This gets at the hobby idea,
brings in the ability to create these
associations you might not ordinarily say.
So in the same way in the 1970s
San Francisco, California,
there was a huge drought.
People drain their swimming pools,
they just looked like empty holes,
but a bunch of kids were like,
these are skate parks,
right?
That's something that comes up from
the default mode network or the
skateboarding kid who wants to be
able to keep practicing in winter.
So he creates a snowboard
and invents snowboarding,
or the army has got Lex San,
a hard plastic that is used in their
windshields of their helicopters and these
windshields are getting scratched up
like nobody's business and the deserts of
Iraq and Afghanistan and in the
training at Fort or Irwin in California,
and they're spending tens
of millions of dollars.
You're placing these lexan
very scratchable windshields
and lo and behold are
these two army reserve,
national reserve guardmen who are
helicopter mechanics and Nascar fans.
And like, well, you know, Nascar,
this is the same luck San
on there and when she has,
but they put these thin mylar sheets on
top of them before every race they're
called tearaways. And at the end
of the race they pull them off.
The mylar took all the hits and scratches
and the windshield's fine, like,
why don't we just put them
on the army helicopters.
They took it from one place
and moved it to another.
They associated it save the army tens
of millions of dollars because the
windshields lifespan doubled and tripled.
But it was already there.
They associated it,
they moved it to another realm.
And very often this is how we
end up seeing innovation happen.
How many of you know Thomas
Edison's electric pen?
Exactly. He's not very proud of
it either. Wasn't very successful.
Ended up in the window of a pawn shop
downtown in New York who should be walking
by. But this guy, Samuel O'reilly,
Samuel O'reilly takes a look at it and
he's a pretty clever guy and he's like, I,
I think I could change the surround.
Samuel O'reilly invents modern
tattooing by changing the electric pen,
moving things in their context from one
context to another is very often where
these innovative ideas come from.
It's the association and that your
default network that's making those
associations, that's
connecting, that's inferring,
that's intuiting between
vastly different things.
Yeah,
so there was a young meteorologist whose
name I wrote down and I can't remember,
it's over here somewhere,
I'll get it at the end,
but he's up in the Arctic in the early
19 hundreds and something just strikes
him that the, the ice kind of looks
like jigsaw puzzle pieces and that's it.
He just notices that it's
like interesting to them.
Year later he's looking at
a globe. He's like, Huh,
you got the continents kind
of look like jigsaw pieces.
I wonder if they were ever together.
And he goes and he checks out the rocks
along South America and along Africa and
he checks out some of the
floor and fun and he's like,
I think these things drifted. He invented
the concept of continental drift,
which eventually took
us to plate tectonics.
A meteorologist making a breakthrough
in geology because I'm an association he
made by looking at the ice in the Arctic.
This is very often how it works.
This idea of curiosity of noticing the
way different things come together and
it's the default network. It's mindlessly
staring out at the ice and be like, Huh.
They look like jigsaw puzzles and then
mindlessly staring at a globe and being
like, oh, the jigsaw puzzles kind
of remind me of the continents.
This is where these things come
together and that's what I'm saying.
It's important to allow ourselves to
be off task because we don't allow
ourselves to access the network otherwise.
So I want you to imagine that gravity
stops working at 10:00 PM and then starts
working again at 7:00 AM how has
our entire culture different?
Okay,
Sas drawing things out,
whatever you can come up with.
Are there nuts over every house or
houses designed more like boats where
everything is locked down?
Our children's sort of tied to their
beds before 7:00 PM how to teenagers play
around with this? How do they rebel
given this, how do they get in trouble?
Given this,
how do people throw nighttime parties?
What does burning man look like?
You could just keep asking yourself this
over and over again, and it seems silly,
but really it's coming out of the
tradition of thought experiments,
which Einstein uses. All
right? Just playing out what
is possible in the universe,
what might occur,
and one last one I'll show you.
The very end is so this,
whoops.
Yeah, this is the world's most boring
video unless you put this music over it.
Now all of a sudden there's tension
and you're probably wondering,
did I put a shark fin in? Is there
going, is it going to pop up?
Are you going to see that fit? Come on,
right? Is it just the mouth going pop out?
I don't have those skills.
This is just like the world's most boring
clouds at the window of an airplane,
but we put the music on and suddenly
your brain's creating a whole universe.
You can do this with any receipt
in the universe. All right?
I'll end the tension. You can literally
take any movie scene you want,
add music to it and watch how it changes.
Watch what happens.
I had one group where somebody shouted
out last scene of Casablanca and somebody
shouted out, we are the champions by
Queen, and they thought they had me.
They thought they nailed me and I
was a little nervous. I was like,
I don't know how this is going to go.
So we go to youtube but bring up the
Casablanca, put it on mute, we bring up,
we are the champions. Turn
it on, start the two of them.
We start watching and it's shocking how
it starts to line up and as the plane
starts to take off and
else's being taken away,
the music is crescendoing
and Freddy Mercury going,
we the jab and you're like,
oh my God,
it's so moving and it's totally
random and play this game.
Literally play this game
and it sounds silly,
but it's amazing how it sets you up for.
Then being able to connect to things
you are narrowly would never think would
work and that's where those
breakthroughs come from. So there's,
there's play involved, there's a craft
involved, there's practice involved.
There are these tools. It's, but
it's not something in theory,
it's something you do.
It's a way you are in the world.
And so you have the ability,
you have the brain for this,
you have all the parts for it. Everybody
does. We just have to use them,
practice with them, and get
comfortable with them. And that's,
that's why we wrote the
book. See, that's nicer.
Thank you.